and one of the top insiders of the
Association covering it as he does for
ESPN our friends at the worldwide leader
in sports always love having Brian Wynn
Horst on the show Brian thanks for
calling in appreciate it
yeah you know rich at some point with
when we have these chants to people
don't have symptoms have a chance to get
these tests I wonder if like you'll be
rooting for a positive that you'll be
rooting that you had and didn't know
unroll peace you'll get the test back
and says oh yeah you had like yes I had
it I had it and but we we also still
just don't know what that means we still
don't know what that means we don't mean
we don't know if that truly means we're
immune or we immune for a time a period
of time that doesn't mean that we can
all go to some concert you know or or
sporting event but it would mean
potentially that we could donate blood
to help somebody right now which I would
do in a heartbeat if I knew that you
know so and the reason why we bring this
all up is in the prism of what a sports
league can open back up again I give you
the floor and what what the NBA is
currently internally discussing on that
front as best you know yeah you know
I've been I've been scolded by people in
the league in the last few days for
being too pessimistic so I'm I'm going
to just try to play it straight down the
middle of the fairway here you know I
have spent a lot of time rich talking to
people you know who are in China or
involved with the Chinese Basketball
Association and I can hear I rolls
because they say well listen China isn't
always truthful and I agree of course
they're not but I don't have a selection
of 15 different leagues in eight
different countries that I can look
there are two or three months ahead of
us I have to work with what we have and
in both China and Japan they've had
setbacks in terms of basketball now
baseball
they're trying in Korea and baseball's a
very different sport it's open air
there's not as much contact although
you're touching the ball to different
sport altogether but those leagues have
had difficulty going there because of a
switch we're just talking about
asymptomatic carriers so in so the until
you have a test that is number one work
but you don't have to wait five or six
days for number two that you can take it
without taking resources away from the
front lines that I really don't think
we're going to get out of the batter's
box and I know that there are people
saying that oh these testing these tests
are going to be available and in six
weeks or three weeks or 15 minutes or
whatever let me know when they're
available don't don't promise me when
they're available because I remember a
couple of weeks ago when nobody could
find a test anywhere and the Surgeon
General saying no problem we'll have a
million tests by the end of the week I
didn't happen so don't don't give me any
any deadlines about products don't exist
so until we have testing there is really
difficult to have any real discussion
about getting back until that exists and
they don't have that ubiquitously yet in
China where they can get their league
back on its feet I think that's
important to realize well I guess
there's also apps that I'm reading about
that if people report I'm feeling well
or I'm reporting I'm not feeling well
that you may be able to be better
contact tracing all of this but you're
right we're not we're not anywhere close
that's great for society but I can feel
fine and I may be carrying it and giving
it to you that's that's what the issue
has been in China is the asymptomatic
carriers now there's good news in China
I think I read today I can't say for
sure I heard that the Wuhan airport
reopened and I know that there that city
is coming back to alive that's a really
good sign for us that they're getting
past it but it's it's it's the people
that don't know that they have it that
aren't even showing a temperature
because that's the one thing that you
know people are saying is what will test
people's temperatures every time they
walk in and out of the building well
that may identify somebody who's
beginning to show symptoms but if you
don't have symptoms it's not going to
help asymptomatic carriers are the
stumbling block to returning to sports
from a medical standpoint then there's
obviously the societal and political
standpoint of you better not be taking
away from from society by doing
yeah Reuters is reporting Brian Wynn
horse to get ESPN MBA solder here
Reuters is reporting people are now
being allowed to leave a Wuhan so this
is 76 days of containment and now they
have been apparently released from
quarantine there and we all know that
this outbreak was first known about and
you're reading about reports that the
intelligence community did tell you no
the white house back in November that
this is a possibility of this blowing up
to the way that we're in right now so
you just do the math that's six months
of of what you know of going from first
being born to six months later Wuhan is
is people are allowed to leave I mean
you could get guests do the math and
wonder how a sports league could get
started again when when China is still
going through all that Brian so the
question is let let's just I guess go
down a little bit of a fun spot here is
there a possibility of horse contests I
mean just some way shape or form we're
seeing also many NBA stars on on
Instagram live feeds to potentially
connect these guys together for our
viewing enjoyment Brian yeah they've
been working Dave been working on that
for a couple of weeks and I think once
they smooth out the tech I do think that
something like that could happen I think
that will really be fun
also not everybody has courts to play on
I mean I saw a honest gave it interview
last week where he said he doesn't have
a court at his house I know that sounds
crazy but in Milwaukee you know it's
hard to go outside for much of the year
right if you don't have an indoor you
know I
Yama's can afford an indoor gym but not
every not every been ba players gonna
have it I'm sure was not something he
thought was our issue was getting a
basketball hoop so some of these guys
can't it would have to leave their house
and that's a whole other thing so yes I
do think that that is something that can
be done and I've actually really enjoyed
watching some of the old games I know
that that's good not lasting very long
for a lot of people but I've enjoyed it
but you know the real the real reality
here is there's just so so so many
things that to overcome and I know that
there's excitement about
this report about baseball and there's
some excitement about this report about
tests and I am all for hope and optimism
I really hope it comes through but one
of the things that is a big factor for
the NBA rich is how willing what is
their willingness to bleed into next
season because Adam silver now twice has
mentioned that he doesn't want to harm
next season and that creates an
artificial backstop because I can kind
of see it if you're the NBA you have
damage to this year significant damage
do you want to you know what is worse
damaging to seasons taking major
financial hits in two seasons or
limiting the damage to one season that
is a really big complex question that is
going to be a factor going forward here
because in theory rich you could restart
the NBA in October and play the last
month of the regular season then play
the playoffs take off the holidays and
restart after the Super Bowl with
another season in it there's nothing
stopping you from doing that right
except for the fact that it bastardized
as the schedule and changes everything
up and and so it's it may just be a
function of the of the calendar and
limiting the damage as much as fighting
off the disease at this point yeah I'm
Brian win horse here in the Rich Eisen
show I mean I forget who we were talking
about it with Chris last week that might
have been mark Stein your colleague from
from the times that necessity could be
the mother of invention that there's a
large group of as a large group of
individuals in the Association I guess
Cuban being one of them who thinks the
league should start on Christmas Day
anyway and run and run through the
summer and you start reconfiguring when
you do you draft in your summer league
and it's a better schedule for the NBA
anyway that that might lead to this that
the ability to start the next season not
until then might actually show a better
way for the NBA in a post corona virus
pandemic world what do you think about
that yeah that is true and Adam silver
is even admitted that the that the
calendar may look different after this
and you know this is a crisis but there
can be some opportunities that are that
arise from it but you know the one thing
that is clear to me now while the MBA is
working with health officials and
working with Laboratories on things the
discussions that they have had with
their players which they have to go up
with a deal here rich through the next
few days because the next paychecks are
due April 15th and the NBA doesn't
intend to pay them all and the NBA has
the right within their contract to just
quit paying the players altogether they
don't want to do that they don't want to
create an animus but they've got to make
a deal with their players Major League
Baseball already made a deal with it
with their players they've got to make a
deal with their players about how
they're going to go forward with this
other gonna sort of set aside money to
to shelter the damage that's happening
and in my understanding is they talked
the Union and players they're not
talking about the restart we're not
talking about what parameters they would
you know be willing to play in they're
only talking about the finances and I
think that's a responsible thing to do
that's exactly what you should be doing
to protect the league but it's an
indication of how far away they are from
knowing how this is gonna look yeah I
know I know what baseball said Brian but
the NBA was the first to to shut down
and and and I've said it before I'll say
it again here I don't know if I said it
with you before but Rudy Gobert testing
positive for kovat 19 with fans in the
building in Oklahoma City and a referee
in Sacramento that had been around the
Jazz the day before canceling that game
and the NBA just shutting down changed
the way the entire country was viewing
this entire situation I mean the whole
social distancing and we need to stay
home and we need to change the way that
we fundamentally live in this country
was led by the National Basketball
Association which led the way for the
NCAA to wake up in time to cancel most
of their tournaments and the NCAA
tournament which led to an entire sea
change of the way that we did everything
hockey followed etc and so on and so
forth we're still only two plus weeks
removed from the Indian Wells tournament
being cancelled and many people there
who were involved in the tournament
saying why are we doing this that's
totally
changed and the association is in a
leadership role I think and I'm
wondering if that is in any way shape or
form forming their beliefs in talking
about all this Brian well they hope so
but the reality is they didn't have a
choice rich when Rudy Gobert tested
positive they had to stay had to shut
down they just slap it on the timeline
they were the first to deal with that I
actually think that Indian dwells in the
Ivy League in terms of leading the pack
you know deserve some some some bravery
points for that remember when they shut
the league down the NBA hadn't even
announced that they were taking fans out
there were fans and in the arena's that
night so I think it is a something that
the NBA ended up doing that could that
could be somewhat important but I'm not
going to give them points for being
Noble but Adam silver I think just said
that he does you know if they are in
position to sort of be the thing that
comes back and holds it holds the first
championship and stuff like that and I
do think that's important to them but it
would be important to them whether they
were the first to shut down and assess
and in some ways playing basketball is
is easier because you don't have to have
a hundred yard field you don't have to
have a stadium that needs the kind of
maintenance that you know you may not be
able to do if there's ten games on it a
day you know it's a smaller it's a
smallish number of players that you'd
have to worry about you know it's not up
a 25 man baseball roster or whatever
they want to make the rosters it's
certainly not what you would need for a
football team that said it's very
physical in contact close sport and that
makes it difficult you know you read
different things from these experts who
talk about this and it's it's just
really really hard to form any sort of
prediction that's why I think the NBA is
being responsible number one dealing
with the finances right now because
that's one thing that they can control
and saying to everybody who will listen
look we're not going to do anything
until we get to May when we get to May
we're going to reevaluate and I know
that that's hard for people who who are
trying to look
for good news and trying to look for
optimism and we may have optimism by May
first but right now I just don't think
that the league can move at a fast pace
on doing anything I do have to say you
are correct and we were the day of art
we did a show on that Wednesday when
Rudy Gobert of that night tested
positive we had Robin Harris the
executive director of the Ivy League on
our show to explain her decision to
cancel her tournament to cancel the
men's and women's basketball
championships and name to schools and
men and women the two teams that would
represent them in an NC double-a
tournament that eventually got canceled
so that is correct in pointing that out
that she was the first in that regard
Brian Wynn Horst here in the Rich Eisen
show you mentioned how you're enjoying
watching old school basketball I do
believe as as we're talking I could see
on the on the sports mix in front of me
here I do believe Grant Hill just sent
Dino Raja to the line for two shots on
any TV I am enjoying this immensely
great Dino Raja sorry sorry I did see
the other night in old school Atlanta
Hawks New York Knicks contest Dominique
battling it out I'm I'm loving all this
Brian and and that nostalgia is about to
be ratcheted up with the Jordan
documentary the last dance coming on
ESPN what is there anything you know
about this that you can help preview it
what what what what can we expect out of
this 10-part doc that starts a couple
Sundays from now at the first two parts
yeah I didn't quite so I do quite a bit
of work with Scottie Pippen and I've
talked with him about it a little bit I
didn't I didn't quite understand what
this was I didn't understand that there
was like a documentary crew with the
Bulls that season or somebody was
filming for a doc I want to know that
word where's the footage been for
20-plus years salted away and this oh
yeah I don't you know I don't a lot of
this is you know it's crazy but you know
in in listening to pip and talk about
that season which ended in the iconic
moment of the shot in Jordan head in in
Utah you know there was a lot of stuff
with the Bulls at that time and you know
not only that but because of the the
gravity of this project and because
Jordan supported it they got all of the
being all of the principles to sit down
for interviews and that's the one thing
that I can tell you just being around a
little bit is what you really want is
you really want the people who no longer
have skin in the game who are willing to
talk I get to be around a lot of retired
newly retired players at ESPN I'm you
know you do two at the NFL Network
and listen to these guys tell stories I
go oh my god I wish I do this five years
ago oh she could have beside years ago
and it just opened so much up so that's
what I really want to see is not only
the footage but you know what did Phil
Jackson say what was Phil Jackson going
to say about what was going on with that
team at that time and about Michael and
I don't you know I'm not privy to any
details of what's in the dock they keep
that the 34:30 stuff sort of out of our
realm on purpose but you know it's ten
hours I'm pretty sure ten episodes that
they're going to over five showings um
that's a lot of footage they have
something special there so what do you
think what what do you what do you want
to learn most dude was it a push off on
Brian Russell or I mean what like what
what do what do you want to glean out of
this what do you think needs to be
answered let's put it that way the most
from the Jordan story that everybody
always wants his whitey retire you know
why did he really really really retire I
don't know if we're going to get that
and it doesn't exactly definitely cover
that time period
that's what I'd love to know and then I
also want to know why he retired for the
second time in 98 when he had an
opportunity to keep going and I think
that that will be that will be covered
because they could have they could have
easily won eight or plus in titles in a
row and so that that that those are the
types of behind the scenes stuff that
I'm looking for but also remember that
Bulls team was such a rock star filled
team
you know Rodman I remember the Chicago
Tribune used to keep a record in the
paper every day of the Bulls records
with his different hair colors and he
advises ladies hair every few days and
you had Phil Jackson on his you know on
his way out and and all the drama with
that and Jordan and Pippen and and you
know him getting into a fight with Steve
Kerr and punching Steve Kerr out and the
poker games on the plains and and the
gambling on the Gulf sand and Jordan
playing thirty six in the morning and
then showing up at night and dropping 38
like there was a lot of stuff going on
with that Bulls team they were at the
top of their game everybody was coming
out for them and there was one game that
year they were so much interest in them
the in Jordan's last game in Atlanta
they thought was his last game they play
in the Georgia Dome and they got 65,000
people so watch a regular-season mdaa
game I mean the the Rockstar status of
that team and when we think like oh man
the Miami Heat oh man the the Golden
State Warriors and there was maybe no
team more famous they were you know they
were the at the top of their games and
so to capture footage from that and the
other thing is we all remember this this
is not a documentary you know about the
50s where most of us weren't around or
don't remember right remember and so for
people of a certain age it's gonna be
like you know what that's one of the
things I loved about the oj documentary
in the oj stuff that happened I mean I
remember living through it when I was in
high school and so this is going to be
again that not only learning but the
nostalgia part of it to so many people I
think is something that will really
invigorate oh no no no doubt about it
but I'm man today before I let you go to
ask this question are you intimating
that Jordan's retirement the first time
was not because he really wanted to
scratch that baseball itch I mean you
know that's what he says sure I believe
it I just I'd like to you know who knows
even go there you and I won't even go
there right now on YouTube right I don't
know I don't know
I'd like to know but don't you think
that there's a chance that you're in
this documentary like Oh God play call
there is Brian I am I am for sure going
to at one point just be going about my
business and my Twitter timeline will
explode with look at you with your hair
just as it did in the last 12 hours
because SportsCenter tweeted out and
instagrammed out a bunch of SportsCenter
commercials including me with Stuart and
Kobe I get all of these screen grabs
from friends texts tweets everything
look at you with hair yeah I had hair
you know I don't understand what the big
thing is you think you're Sports Center
primer what were your sports that are
prime year this is in your prime
SportsCenter you yeah I got there in 96
so but the the issue there's two issues
one is yes I can be doing a Sports
Center call from exactly what you're
talking about but the odds are Stuart
Scott did the highlight because there
was no way on this green earth that
Michael Jordan would succeed at anything
significantly and I would get that
highlight not a chance
it's iffy that I'm in the last dance
let's put it that way
iffy thanks to the call Brian appreciate
it glad you're healthy and well let's
chat soon
that's Jetson that's Brian when Horst
and ESPN NBN sire hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here